[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Administration is suing the Arizona
governor over an attempt to fill in the
border wall this is pretty interesting
Doug Ducey who's a republican has been
sued by the Biden Administration over
his construction of a barrier made of
double stacked shipping containers along
parts of the U.S Mexico border so Ducey
launched this effort to fill in gaps in
Trump's border wall
and federal authorities have said it's
not a lawful barrier because it's on U.S
land which I guess it's too far into U.S
land to be considered a legal border and
the lawsuit asks Arizona to stop
building it and to remove the containers
that it's technically trespassing on
Federal Land uh and you know this is one
of these things Pat where
there's like there's a conversation
that's happening about the wall and it's
happening parallel to but disconnected
from the real conversation we should be
having about immigration which is let's
fix DACA let's fix the Asylum system
let's uh understand that if we want to
deal with people here illegally we would
be much better served putting more
resources into overstayed visas you know
there's this long list of things that we
could go through and instead we're just
arguing about building and taking down
border walls all of those things would
require a good faith effort from
Republicans though like they don't
actually want to solve issues dealing
with immigration they just want to
fear-monger about yes they want to in
some cases make the problem worse so
that Democrats who are in charge look
even worse and then lose to Republicans
in the next election cycle I think
that's exactly what's going on here so
they're not interested in DACA they're
not interested in Visa overstays it's
all about the wall because the wall is
like a tangible symbol so it's both
tangible and representative of like it's
it's interesting because it's both it's
it's a physical thing and also
the opinion of where one stands on
immigration is mediated by what do you
think about this physical thing and it's
a physical thing that exists in some
places but not in other places like
along the Rio Grande for example right
so when you want to make the argument
that Trump did so much for immigration
and he built the wall you can do that
because you can show portions of the
wall but then when you talk about how
Biden didn't complete the wall or it was
only three weeks away from being
finished and Biden could have just
filled in the gaps but he didn't then
you can also show those places too where
the wall isn't in place and you can show
these shipping containers instead to
make a point about that so it's it's
just such harebrained politics at such
low level discourse I think and so yeah
you're right to point out this is just
another political stunt I'm not sure if
it's going to backfire on Doug Ducey
politically But ultimately he's going to
not have his way on this because Katie
Hobbs will soon be the governor and can
get rid of this uh something he's
pulling there's also all sorts of other
environment and law enforcement concerns
so here are some examples the shipping
container wall I guess for lack of a
better term is blocking 30 ephemeral
water courses where water is supposed to
be moving or supposed to water naturally
moves but it's being blocked so it's
going to block natural Watershed
patterns this will damage the soil it'll
damage vegetation Etc so it's like
environmental concerns it's also hurting
law enforcement functions because Forest
services are unable to carry out
official duties National Forest system
lands are being occupied by armed
private security guards it's a whole
complete and total mess
yeah and the question is how will the
Biden team respond to this because of
course they can move in and get rid of
the shipping containers it's federal
land it's not state land so there's a
lot that they can do to get rid of the
shipping containers on the ground but
when it comes to actual penalties and
stopping this sort of thing from
happening in the future that's a big
question mark as well because I'd
imagine you could probably find the
state and and punish the government in
some sort of way but the right-wing
governments over there could just spin
that into saying oh we'll see Democrats
are trying to make our situation even
worse they're not even willing to fix
immigration they're not willing to build
the wall and on top of all that when we
try to put forward our best efforts to
solve all these problems they hit us
with all these fines and environmental
regulations right and it may end up
making Biden look even worse among the
selector these things can quickly become
political quagmires and messes and sort
of bad for anybody but the biggest
losers really in all of this are all of
us who just want to actually make
progress on the issue of immigration not
mediated by a wall whether it's made of
rebar or shipping containers or whatever
the case may be and very little to no
progress happening there so we'll see
what ultimately happens Katie hops will
be the governor she's against this wall
this it feels weird even calling it a
wall but I don't know what else to call
it
um so we'll follow it and see if there
are any changes uh Twitter owner Elon
Musk is now taking legal action against
the holder of a Twitter account which
tracks musk's private jet Elon Musk is
arguing that it puts his son at risk to
have his private jet track this is an
account on Twitter called Elon jet it
had more than half a million followers
but was suspended yesterday the owner is
a 20 year old named Jack Sweeney who
uses publicly available flight traffic
information every time Elon Musk jet
takes off and lands and musk says this
is not allowed because it is a physical
risk a security risk to him and his
family he said last night a car carrying
a car carrying Little X which I guess is
the nickname for one of his kids I don't
know you know they all have kind of
unusual names strange names was followed
by a stalker thinking it was musk who
later blocked the car from moving and
climbed on the hood and that it all was
probably related to the fact that that
account made clear that Elon musk's jet
was coming in and the argument that
they're making
is that this can has always been against
Twitter policy that any account
revealing people's real-time locations
are going to be suspended and
um the idea is you're revealing the
real-time physical location of Elon
musk's Jet and by definition Elon Musk
and potentially his family now I have to
tell you
I sympathize with these concerns because
think whatever you want about Elon Musk
people like Elon Musk
who are so well known
some portion of people are crazy and
violent okay and so I would share Elon
musk's concerns I think the problem is
that there's a double standard when it
comes to what is and isn't allowed on
Twitter and what's encouraged on Twitter
and much of it seems to be guided by
just Elon musk's personal preferences
and desires yeah I absolutely agree with
you I too am sympathetic with making
this against the rules over at Twitter
because it does sound like doxing right
if the whole point behind rules against
uh giving out people's home addresses is
the idea that well people could use that
information to Target those people they
could show up to their house at night
yes with the reasonable assumption that
they're going to be there it stands to
reason you can apply the same logic to
flight paths right if you if you know
that a private jet is going to be taking
off from somewhere and Landing it
somewhere at a specific times then
people could go to those places they
know that these people are going to be
there and they could talk Target them
that way I know it's kind of easy to
maybe dismiss this to some because you
know these are private jets and so
they're wealthy individuals and so maybe
people inherently just have less
sympathy surrounding that sort of thing
but it it is quite similar right you
know the real-time location of these
people and maybe that's best kept off
Twitter but at the same time it's only
now that this issue affects him that he
wants to raise alarms about it that he
wants to change the policy over at
Twitter not when it was affecting other
people and this is also not the first
time that he's done this too uh he um
who said that he doesn't want Alex Jones
to come back to the platform because of
Jones's comments that he said about you
know Sandy Hook yes because Elon Musk
was saying oh well my son died in my
arms and I'm really against anyone who
targets children for their own benefit
so it was only so he's trying to be like
one of these Free Speech Warrior types
but then when it came to Alex Jones he
was against putting him back on the
platform because uh Elon was personally
perturbed by something that Jones did
now he's doing it with the flight paths
like we see what's going on here it's
all about elon's self-interest by the
way if this entire jet thing rings a
bell the kid who runs this account is
the same one that some time ago Elon
Musk offered five thousand dollars to to
shut it down and the guy said no so uh
it's it's still the very same account
that's lowballing too right I know
multi-multi-billionaire and Elon Musk
this is putting my family and children
at existential risk would you take five
grand I've got a hundred billion I know
it seems cheap right so to the average
person that's probably a couple of
pennies right if you did the math on
that so I I would imagine he doesn't
want to offer too much money because
then you encourage copycat correct do
the exact same thing but still throw the
kid 100 grander so that would be good
hey here is something super interesting
Georgia's Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger is calling for Georgia to
end its practice of runoff elections
runoff elections are only held in two
states at this point when a candidate
doesn't get to 50 percent of the vote
this is why we had the runoff between
Raphael Warnock and Herschel Walker on
December 6th because on November 8th
neither candidate achieved 50 of the
vote and there is this 50 requirement in
Georgia if you don't get fifty percent
because there's multiple can three
candidates or more you hold a runoff
with just the top two vote Getters
um remind me Pat is this also why there
were two special elections in 2020 it
was this very same fifty percent rule
same exact reason no candidate got over
50 and so they had to have the runoffs
so Brad raffensberger is saying we're
one of the only states that does this
we're one of the only states where it
often seems to happen uh no one wants to
be dealing with politics in the middle
of family holidays let's just get rid of
this thing now one for me one of the
interesting questions would be
has the winner of the runoff
differed from the winner of the
multi-way race and with Herschel Walker
and Rafael Warnock Warnock got a
plurality of the vote on November 8th
and then he got a majority of the vote
on December 6th I don't remember the
2020 results did Leffler or Purdue win
and then lose or did they I just don't
remember Pat offhand I'm not sure uh I'm
sure we can look into that and get an
answer for our audience but I kind of
sympathize with the logic of saying well
we want a majority of people to support
the candidate who ends up representing
the state but at the same time it just
seems so difficult to do logistically
and you have all these extra elections
yeah people get sick of casting their
ballots over and over again so to me I
think it makes sense to get rid of this
and also if you look at like the
historical reasons for why they put this
in place to begin with it has to do with
like Jim Crow era legislation where they
were trying to prevent black candidates
from getting elected with the idea being
well you can have the majority of white
voters coalesce around a white candidate
and that person can be elected instead
so going back to 2020
Purdue did get more vote than Asaf in
the general November 3rd 2020 election
and then OS of one on the other hand
Warnock did do better than Leffler in
the November third election and then
also one in the runoff so in these three
examples Walker Warnock Warnock Lefler
Purdue Asaf in two of three the runoff
winner was the same as in the main
election in one it was different I agree
with getting rid of it quite frankly I I
I don't like it right and of course the
2020 election was a little bit different
because in the interim between the
general and the runoff you had Trump
basically encouraging Republicans not to
vote to send a message about voter fraud
and all that so we don't know if the
results would have been different if he
wasn't out there doing that sort of
thing and just the fact that Georgia has
become a purple State I think is Raising
so much attention to this issue because
Louisiana is the other state that has
this for the general election but
there's such a red state that this issue
probably just doesn't come up that much
yeah and it's it's just kind of annoying
and I'd imagine it's annoying for voters
in Georgia already like they would have
had to vote for Raphael Warnock three
times this year once in the primaries
once in the general rights in the runoff
it's already difficult enough to get
people to turn out to vote if you're
making them do it like every month or so
it seems then they're going to be even
less likely to to go to the polls when
you want them to I want to mention one
more thing if I can Pat many of you
emailed me with tears in your eyes and
it's weird that I could tell you we're
crying even though it was written but I
could saying David are you going to
cover live Trump's major announcement
yesterday Donald Trump announced an
announcement saying I'm going to be
making a huge announcement tomorrow and
speculation was is Trump dropping out of
the race is Trump announcing a VP really
early what what could this be
the announcement happened about an hour
ago as of right now Trump announced a
digital trading card collection that's
the announcement can you imagine both
something mo more meaningless and more
Unbecoming of a former president of the
United States yeah because I was
wondering what could possibly be the
announcement right he's already
announced that he's running for
president right it has to be that he's
dropping out or something specific to do
with his candidacy no it's this Trading
Card Set it's insane and it's leaving me
wondering even more about them like are
all the trading cards featuring Trump do
they have like different senators and
family members of trump who are also
going to appear on these trading cards
uh should we make a trading card set of
our own with David packman show
characters like what's what happened
next on this I think I'm gonna do
nothing with trading cards that's where
I'm leading that's I'm feeling really
strongly about that now
what about doing some sort of nft
equivalent I thought I thought Trump may
go in this route we have so many things
going on I think I'm gonna opt out of
that I mean and by the way speaking of
which one of the things I've had going
on now for a while is the new studio I
know it still looks the same but I'm in
a completely brand new studio and people
have been writing in about the echo when
we first moved in there was no rug and
no acoustic panel treatment and my voice
was just bouncing everywhere and it was
so echoey and every day I'm adding about
15 acoustic panels to the walls
yesterday a nice shag rug came in which
noticeably reduced the echo so we're not
there yet I I'm still hearing a little
bit of an echo in the room but we're
getting there and we should expect that
basically every show the audio will
improve a tiny bit the other thing also
I previously had my microphone mounted
on the desk and so I would get sound
transfer when I would touch the desk or
move my mouse I now have a beautifully
heavy duty this thing is it's like 50
pounds beautifully Heavy Duty mic stand
that goes on the floor so now I can
touch my desk and I'm getting no sound
transfer so I think these are dramatic
improvements Pat
still not going to help the sound
transfer when you punch the microphone
every now and then but when you touch
the desk it's going to help a great deal
and also I think this could encourage
you to become a hoarder because the more
stuff that you have in the room the more
the echo will improve away so I know you
have been going in the direction of
being more and more minimalist over the
years right we're going to have to
reverse that I'm going to have to stuff
this room full of crap by the way I also
have just to show people as a temporary
thing from the old Studio I have a
single foam panel that I put like right
next to me just to mimic until I can get
more foam panels on the wall I have this
is like my friend when I'm filming it's
my acoustic foam panel uh but so you
know doing everything we can and it's
all going to be improved very very soon
you have that next to you like a my
pillow exactly my pillow on my side too
also muffle the sound that I'm getting
around here it's a beautiful panel but
yeah we're making improvements and I
think that is sort of a symbol of what's
to come right it's just one panel for
now but soon enough we're going to have
oh God and we just lost Pat everything
going wrong here we're gonna have what
Pat did we just lose Pat oh Pat's back
now uh wow at such a critical moment we
lost Pat briefly but he is back
I think we gotta end it there yeah and
now his mic volume went down 80 it's
crazy all right folks we're gonna end
the
book so we can troubleshoot but we will
be back with a brand new show tomorrow
and a new bonus show